niantic Labs has released a new update
for the massively popular Pokemon go I'm
Lucy and welcome to you're gonna use
this frying pan as a drying pan gamespot
news updates among other things the
update introduces a new reminder not to
play the game while driving a car
typically speaking playing a video game
while driving or doing anything else
that distracts you while driving is a
bad idea the patch notes were listed on
the official niantic website in addition
to the new reminder not to play while
traveling above a certain speed there
are bug fixes and the ability to change
your nickname it's not mentioned in the
patch notes but apparently the nearby
feature is replaced by sightings niantic
says we're currently testing a variation
of the nearby Pokemon feature with a
subset of users during this period you
may see some variation in the nearby
pokemon UI with citing the game will
actually show you a picture of the polka
stop where you can find a specific
Pokemon which seems a lot easier than
the misleading one two three step
feature other fixes include making
improvements to the accuracy of a
curveball throw and fixing achievements
showing incorrect metal icons they've
also resolved issues with the battery
saver mode on iOS and have therefore
re-enabled the feature as well as added
visuals of team leaders Candela Blanche
and sparks so what do you make of the
update and how are you finding the new
sighting system let me know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at least James games for
more on Pokemon go make sure you head
over to gamespot com